thank you uh good morning so we're gonna
uh given some of the talks i've seen
sort of take a slightly different uh
track here we're gonna be talking about
genetic data um and uh as you mentioned
we launched ancestry dna
uh in may of 2012 and since then we've
started to acquire a lot of data and
i'll show you some of the some of the
data that we have i'll talk to some of
the challenges happy to answer some of
the questions this is obviously a pretty
brief talk
there's a lot of really interesting uh
data in science on the back end that
that leads to this but i wanted to start
off with something that we've been sort
of really pushing lately which is sort
of the 2010 census um
ethnicity and sort of race
uh document right and so this is what
the u.s you know government is putting
out saying hey what's your race what's
your ethnicity you can see that there's
uh
a couple different areas for hispanics
and then for different races i'm going
to get back to this a little later but i
want to keep that in mind right now
so
in terms of ancestry dna again launched
may 2012 we have probably the fastest
growing database certainly one of the
fastest growing databases of genetic
information here's where we dropped the
price to 99 you see a nice inflection
point and when we put it on sale
the price elasticity is fantastic so we
now have over 500 000
genotyped samples meaning we've actually
acquired and actually analyzed the dna
we also bank all of the dna for for the
future we think we'll be at a point
where we'll have over a million samples
probably in early 2015 middle of 2015.
um and this is really a huge effort we
there is no single database that
contains this much uh uh information
so let me just take a step back because
if you haven't taken the product it sort
of gives you a little perspective um so
the product provides two different
things you give us a saliva sample
you send it to us we send it to a lab in
san diego called illumina illumina
analyzes the data uploads the raw data
to our uh
our lab or our it's not really our lab
it's our offices in san francisco where
we have our data scientists and they do
all the analytics and based on that
simple saliva sample what you get is two
things first is we predict your genetic
ethnicity so basically we predict based
on your dna content where your ancestors
lived hundreds
perhaps thousands of years ago it's
actually fairly accurate and i'll give
you some some data on that
and the second thing we do is we compare
your dna to everyone else in the
database and
uh give you who your genetic cousins are
so what you don't think about is most of
the time you have like first cousins you
some of you may know some second cousins
uh you have third fourth fifth cousins
and you have a lot of them okay uh
basically every generation right it
increases uh dramatically so you have on
average like three four five thousand
fifth cousins okay and so in a database
of five hundred thousand if you do the
math it's actually not that difficult to
find many many of your fourth and fifth
cousins in the database
so
here's just a very simple overview of
what we give you uh with the prediction
we have 26 global regions right now
three years ago right the only thing we
could tell you was that you were african
asian or european and my joke was you
need a mirror not a genetic test
to to do that right so i said i said
you've got to do better than that and
everyone's it's going to be really hard
i'm like yeah i know but we've got to do
better than that so so basically like
any problem you have two things either
you have more genetic diversity that you
can
you know assay that helps you separate
populations or you just collect a lot of
data and eventually right the bell
curves gets a little taller a little you
know a little taller and thinner and
this is what you start to get and so you
really are starting to break populations
now even within europe which is one of
the least diverse populations on the
planet
um and
one of the things that i'm not going to
talk a lot about but we're communicating
to lay consumers that don't have
statistics and math backgrounds right
we've got to be able to convey the
probabilistic nature of what we're
actually giving people right so when we
say you're 25
irish we don't really mean 25.00 right
there's a range we do a lot of work in
bootstrapping to make sure that we have
a good range but it's a rich so we try
to do this and we actually are
constantly talking to the customer
trying to understand did you
you know properly understand what we're
conveying to you
and then the matches um are are here um
we basically compared to everyone in the
database we show here's the match here's
the confidence which is basically a
positive predictive value or precision
which is what customers really seem to
associate with
and then we have this little thing on
the site that's a shaky leaf and the
shaky leaf basically says not only do we
think that your genetic cousin's based
on the genetics but we also believe that
by looking at both of your family trees
on the website we actually know who your
common ancestor is and when you do that
this is what you get and in this
particular case you have a third great
grandparents of these two customers
that we've identified and we actually
tell you the path so what we're trying
to do we're starting to do is really
connect everyone in this database both
genetically and when there's family
trees
with the family trees
and so as i was saying with the genetic
ethnicity
26 global regions we assay right now
everyone's dna at over 700 000
individual locations or snips if you're
familiar with that terminology so
basically these are areas in the genome
that we know
vary
between
human populations and those are the ones
that actually help us separate
populations out because we're all 99.9
identical right and so most of the our
genome isn't actually very helpful in
actually discerning different
populations
so let me just give you a quick example
well this is before i do that this is a
this is a distribution of the database
it's definitely biased ancestry.com uh
has records uh primarily from the us in
you know the uk
canadia or canada australia etc so the
population is is more biased towards
northern europeans than it is uh you
know a general population of the us and
so we see that in the genetics as well
what's kind of interesting let me just
give you a little sense again if you
haven't looked at how this data performs
one of the one of the areas that's
really interesting particularly for
african americans is when the records
stop in the u.s try to get some sense of
where in western africa
or where uh in the world um they're from
and so western africa and africa general
is one is the most diverse
uh genetically diverse populations right
that's we're out of africa that is the
area that's had the most time to uh to
diverge and so let me just show you
briefly how we were able to get samples
uh from western africa and actually
create this uh ethnicity prediction so
i don't know how familiar you guys are
with just a simple pca
plot but what happens here is if you
look at uh you know benin here you see
that all the people from that area
cluster here and as you move you can
follow the colors in congo you can see
ghana ivory coast you can see mali you
can see benin and then you see senegal
so basically this is a genetic diversity
that we see with frankly very few
samples but you're starting to parse out
that genetic diversity and what you're
starting to see some of you may have
noticed right nigeria already looks like
it's breaking up into two different
regions there are three major tribes
in nigeria and this is what's starting
to happen so as we collect more samples
you're naturally seeing sort of the
samples sort of separate and then we go
back and figure out what is it in those
samples that are distinct from the other
populations and so
some people call this biogeographical
it's not just geography it's religion
it's language it's
it's whatever made sort of held that
group together
is really what we're seeing here in the
genetic profile
and so in terms of the the uh the data
um remember that graph i showed you that
looked pretty impressive of 500 000
samples that's what we're looking at
right here
this is the actual network effect that
we're seeing with respect to cousins so
as the database has grown we're seeing a
you know quadratic growth in the number
of dna matches and in fact if you're of
northern european descent on average you
have 54th cousins today if you were to
take the test that we could identify in
an average about two-thirds cousins
right and this is constantly growing
faster and faster one of the biggest
challenges we have
is on the data computational side right
because what we have to do is now
compare
every day today we are comparing
another person that came into the
database against 520 000 people so it's
700 000 markers against 700 000 markers
against 500 000 people
um and it's always funny when you do the
math right you have to we have to qc the
the the data to make sure you know
something didn't happen in the lab where
the plate rotates or whatever
then we phase the dna and the phasing is
basically we have to impute
mathematically what dna came from mom
and dad so that's an important part we
have to piece the data back together
then we do the admixture as how we call
it in in science or the ethnicity
prediction and then we compare every
single person to the database all that
has to happen in about 40 seconds right
because any more than that you basically
run out of time we're selling 30 to 50
000 tests a month so that has to be
processed very fast so this has actually
been one of the most challenging parts
of this is actually keeping up with the
network effect that we're seeing in the
in the database growth
and so here's some fun data right so now
we're doing a genetic census right so we
say okay who has finish in northwest
russian ethnicity and where do they live
in the united states like where were
they when they ordered the test and you
know we always joke is that people from
finland sort of definitely prefer the
northern states uh and then here are
sort of just a simple wordle of the sort
of the surnames that you see
um you know european jewish you see
heavy population in new york uh very
common surnames
irish
like the stereotype they really are
mostly in massachusetts although we do
see them in other areas uh and they
really are the kelly's and they'll
o'brien's and flynn's
um and then we see the african-american
population primarily in the southeast um
so
um how does that compare to the u.s
census and in some ways it's actually
very consistent right so if you look at
sort of scandinavian
the census would suggest that most of
the the people with scandinavian
backgrounds are in the north irishmore
in the northeast african-american the
southeast and hispanics but what's
really interesting is that most people
self-identify very differently than what
our genetics would predict so for
example um in utah from park city utah
we don't see the english particularly
sticking out there we see scandinavian
much much broader than what people would
self-identify with uh and the irish
people in the northeast seem to be uh
seem to believe that they're more irish
than they are uh and then there's one uh
there's one
interesting one right like the census
actually says american which i'm like
what's that i'm not really sure what
that is right we've done we've done a
study uh which i couldn't find the slide
for this but we've done one where we've
looked at everyone's trees and said
how many generations out do you have to
go to at least have one ancestor that
wasn't born in the united states and the
reality is is that i think it's like by
1900 it's like 98
of the people in our database who
consider themselves american have at
least one person that was born outside
the united states so i find this
american pretty funny um and let me just
show you something else
here's what we call a pedigree view of
ethnicity so again we have the advantage
of having trees so we actually look at
the trees and say okay what was the
birth location of people's trees and and
these these are ones that go back 10 20
generations some of our best customers
and what you see is the hot pink is the
us and and as you would expect you know
there's been a lot of generation here
generations here in the us but then you
start seeing you know the german
immigration you see a lot from scotland
and sweden and then the english uh
continues to grow and not surprisingly
in the 1500s right that was 1600s that's
mainly where it came from but here's
what people miss right this is what
people see and so they say mostly you
know english and american but the
reality is is most people don't have
every single line filled out so if they
did
right here's what happens you you start
filling out the line and then at
ancestry you run out of documents or you
can't find the individual and so people
stop right they stop but their ancestors
didn't stop right so basically this
white area here are ancestors that even
our best customers have no idea where
their ancestors came from right so they
had this biased view because the
documents say you're the curious
relatives right we don't have documents
in other places necessarily so the bias
is well i must be american but in fact
you're really missing a whole lot of
data even the best ones right so i think
the genetics is interesting and we hear
stories all the time where people say
i'm not german and then they go back and
look and they're like oh my tree was so
big i mean some people have a hundred
thousand people in their trees they're
like i forgot that i did have a bunch of
german ancestors and others are actually
going back and trying to find
um you know different ancestors that may
have come because they'll just stop on a
line right they have their favorite line
of someone that's famous or whatever
right and that's the only one they work
on um
and then um
and they've gone back and so it's been
really great um and so some of the other
things we're finding is what we call
hidden african uh or european ethnicity
right so here's the proportion of
western africa that we see in a set of
customers and this uh
this is a little older data but the
graph hasn't changed you see this sort
of interesting distribution right
so we test a lot of celebrities we have
a show who do you think you are on tlc
um so this is all public data
blair underwood we had tested a couple
years ago he's you know sort of average
if you will for uh african american
about 70 80 percent african but 20 to 25
european and that's something that's
really interesting and you see on the
twitter and facebook a lot of african
americans taking the testing i didn't
realize
um that i had european uh in me right
there was one great one that that said
hey i'm actually dark white right that
was his comment and i'm like i love that
right it's great because he so people
are starting to understand through this
genetic test right that they're actually
more admixed or more mixed than they
thought they were then you have vanessa
williams is one of our sponsors he's
about 50 percent um african american
or african i should say
blue eyes we think it's from finland but
haven't confirmed that
uh and then you have all these other you
know quote-unquote white people
that have a small percentage of western
africa they look in the mirror they
don't see it uh but it's there and in
fact uh henry louis gates published an
article recently where as many as 13 of
the whites in south carolina have one or
two percent of western africa right so
we really got to start thinking about
our backgrounds and ethnicity more than
just what we see in the mirror right we
tend to use skin color as the proxy for
you know uh what we believe uh ourselves
to be and it's very different um corey
is the last one he we just did some
testing for america's next top model he
was one of the contestants last year uh
he looks white and he's you know he's
basically about 50 i mean one of his
parents is is african-american right and
the point is it's genetics you don't
inherit things exactly 50 50. everyone
thinks that you inherited 50 50. the
reality is you get half for mom and half
from dad but which half you get
is completely random right
and so
um this is a great
question from my uh
from my science team so on the way to a
talk i gave a talk yesterday and i very
quickly
on my iphone say hey do we have an
estimate of the percentages of hispanics
and african americans in our database
right not thinking runoff and of course
what my team immediately says is well if
we define african americans as greater
than 66 percent then we have 30 388.
i'm like i stepped into this one right
like i knew i knew this right this one's
even better right
if we divide hispanics
as americans plus european iberian
greater than 50 where
neither native american nor european
iberian is greater than 80 percent we
have 14 752.
but of course right it's less clear
because some hispanics have a
significant amount of european south was
it which is a talent so i'm like this is
perfect guys that i couldn't even have
asked for a better slide right like this
is exactly what i wanted but it but it
shows right that that such a simple
question like what's the
african-american percentage what's the
number of hispanics my team doesn't look
at this data anymore right the same way
that our sort of social uh constructs
are right and so this is the date i get
back so this is this is great it makes
it really complicated
um i'm going to switch real briefly and
i'm going to get back to that but you
know the other thing we have is these
networks right in 1790 there was 3.9
million people in the united states okay
and for all we talk about immigration
immigration has still been a small
percentage of of the population growth
in this country right so when you really
do i've done this by subtracting
immigration i've done it by looking at
populate average population growth so
the reality is that a lot of us today
are descendants of these gateway
ancestors that were here in 1790 when we
first did our census okay and so what's
happening is is that we're now starting
to connect people not just we found a
fourth cousin but hey we found 50 of you
right and all 50 of you are descendants
of the same uh of the same ancestor
right so here's a here's a great one
right this one actually this state is
old now it's about twice this big uh in
this data i think we have 400 customers
that are all descendants from um one
ancestor and here's what the actual
genetic
network looks like
and i'm not going to tell you who it is
because we're going to publish this
and it's it's pretty funny it's pretty
famous person immediately we knew that
actually the person the statistician who
did this is from england and he gives me
the name and he goes i go is it anyone
famous he's like nah some of the name
i'm like
okay so you guys would all recognize
we're gonna try to publish this um let
me back up publish this soon um
and by the way i should just say
the people who form these big clusters
are the ones that were really fertile
and really healthy right so these these
uh these groups now had 12 or 13 kids
almost all of them survived and all of
their kids had 12 or 13 kids and all of
them survived so it's actually pretty
straightforward this isn't magic right
so we're as the database grows we're
starting to see bigger and bigger
networks of you know politicians
senators you know other famous people
that were in the states
a long time ago that had large families
and are growing so we're going to start
publishing this the last really fun
thing here is that now that we have so
many descendants of of this couple
we have almost their entire genome
represented in this cluster so we are
reconstructing the genome of these
couples and we're about 70 of the way
there so imagine that right it's gonna
be you know hopefully in another six
months or a year as if
they took our test as if they'd gone to
the website spitting a tube and sent me
the test and this couple you know was
alive in the 1700s right so what we're
starting to do is with enough
descendants everyone has a little piece
of their dna and we put it together like
a lego set so that's becoming really fun
so the other thing we did the other day
was um just looking at degrees of
separation right so we talk about six
degrees of separation you know this is
how you get the you know the whole kevin
bacon game um
and in our hands if you're if you've had
a customer with us roots
and you match against the database you
matched about half
half of one percent of everyone in the
database and then if we take
those people
and match them against the rest of the
database they match over 90 percent of
the database so basically in two degrees
you basically can find a connection to
almost everyone in our database right so
the message here is that we are really
connected and true story when i first
started
uh we gave away 10 000 free tests
because we need to get started right so
we gave 10 000 free tests we did all of
the matching as we call it and the data
came back and i literally said we have
to stop something's clearly wrong these
people can't be as related as we think
that they are uh we we did everything
and in fact we really are as related as
we think we are so i mean it's it's
really kind of crazy
um
in fact my team put this together i
don't think we have 200 people in the
room but the idea is given
uh given the probability that two people
are fourth cousins if there were 200
people in this room um
the probability is about almost 98 the
two of us
are fourth cousins
so i mean this is the power of what
we're starting to see with genetics now
and and by the way this is not uh if you
look at the statistics around our
accuracy or our confidence around it
incredibly high fourth cousins in the
mid 90s to high 90s in terms of our our
ability to accurately predict uh
or our position really a precision
number is about you know 95
so it's really really powerful uh data
so i'm going to end with my uh my own
background so this is my test hopefully
you guys will take it and see what your
backgrounds are
pretty complicated um
definitely have western african and
african roots uh native american
uh this italian greece
some of the european and then western
anybody want to take a guess i don't
know if it's on maybe already on
facebook or something but what's my
background anybody want to guess
so this is what you get if your mom is
cuban
uh and your dad's from the middle east
right so will peop remember the question
with my team what's hispanic well that's
where i get the western africa and the
native american uh and it's funny right
because if you ask my family um they're
like we're white we're white europeans
we never co-mingled with anyone i'm like
yeah sure you did yeah and so and so
it's funny right because it's like there
was you know there was definitely some
some cute african-american and cute
native american uh
uh women that uh that got into our gene
pool uh and then i'm one of the people
that is more italian than anything uh
than than iberian
so go back to this right so how am i
supposed to answer
the census question at this point couple
things one
um
it wasn't until 2000 right that we could
actually allow we would allow anyone to
to put two races down so as you can tell
i don't even like the word race i
struggle with even saying it just
because as we continue to break
right the different genetic components
and and really you know divide people up
if you will in some ways
the word race just seems sort of silly
to me but at least in 2000 was the first
time you could do two
i just put one definition down it says
black or african-american a person
having origin in any
right of the black racial groups in
africa right so there's not even like a
significant amount this is if you have
any
so here's what's really funny right
under my team's definition i'm not even
hispanic right i'm fluent in spanish my
mom was cuban i consider myself hispanic
right so my team
unknowingly right didn't make me
hispanic and what's really funny is
under my team's definition
vanessa williams is not african-american
right so is that right is it wrong the
whole point is it's a little bit
arbitrary right and trying to actually
put these labels on people is starting
to get harder and harder as we actually
start to get the data the genetic data
that underlies people so i would
consider myself hispanic but
genetically you know uh it's a little
harder vanessa williams i think would
probably consider herself
african-american but we have to
recognize she's half european and that's
just the way it is so um so i would hope
and one of our one of our big pushes at
ancestry dna is as we're pushing this
data out we're going to try to get a
talk at south by southwest and and just
get people to understand that things are
more complicated than they are i would
love it if we just drop the word race
all together just acknowledge it that
we're just
very similar and very connected but at
the same time there are things that
separate us culturally and genetically
and so
this is my team and thank you for the
opportunity appreciate it